coronavirus cases at nursing homes are
also spiking again in the first week of
november new cases tied to nursing homes
surpassed
24 000 according to the kovid tracking
project
that's the worst it's been since early
august nursing home fatalities over the
week
top 2500 carter evans now reports from
salt lake city
craig watson visited his mother ray at
the avalon valley rehabilitation center
in salt lake city every sunday
until early march when the facility
closed to visitors
i had no idea i would never see her
again almost five months later
ray tested positive for coronavirus
watson could only say goodbye over
facetime
the night before she passed away what's
your favorite memory of your mom
she was a character i mean my favorite
memory of her was her personality
she was always good and up for anything
and she was just a lot of fun and
i miss that while most facilities have
banned outside visitors
residents are still at risk of being
exposed to the virus through
unknowing caretakers frustrated for us
because we couldn't see her
but there's people from the outside that
are probably more likely exposed than we
are
going in there every day we cannot
create a bubble
around the elderly folks living in
nursing homes
rebecca gurgas studies public health
policy at the university of chicago
in a newly published paper she looked at
six states currently experiencing surges
including utah
as cases in the community rose she found
weekly cases among nursing home staff
more than tripled and resident cases
more than quadrupled from june to
october
we find that community spread is the
largest predictor of which nursing homes
experience cases and then which nursing
home
experience a severe outbreak with lots
of deaths part of the solution includes
rapid testing of staff on site 87
percent of nursing homes now have access
to rapid testing machines
but a kaiser health news study says
concerns about accuracy
and a shortage of testing supplies have
prompted many facilities to continue to
send samples to
laboratories experts believe eliminating
test delays and reducing community
spread
are critical to reducing nursing home
infections
i just think it's common sense to do
everything we can whether you believe
it's political or not political
it just seems common sense to protect
the most vulnerable among us
now the avalon valley rehabilitation
center says it can't comment on
individual patients but it does use
outside contractors
like nurses and therapy staff and their
screening process they say
does meet federal standards they also
say they're thankful for
increased testing capabilities including
that new rapid test machine
gail all right thank you very much
carter